Film Courage: Chris off-camera we were talking about
MonsterPalooza and you know horror
geeks versus horror nerds and things
like that. You have such a knowledge and
love for movies. How far does that go
back and where does it come from? Chris von Hoffmann, Filmmaker: I mean
it goes back pretty far. I mean like I
think probably around like 5 or 6 years
old it's probably when I started I
become like very um immersed in movies
and like you know I mean that's pretty
much like the mate that's I mean you
know I had some side fads here in there
growing up like movies was always like
the major thing I was always very um it
was like movie isn't like WWF or WWE now
it's like there's like the two things I
was like obsessed with throughout like
growing up as a child that was kind of
defined my personality I felt and and
but like movie I mean like I think yeah
i mean i think i think teenage mutant
into turtles like that that that movie
from like 1992 or 91 that was like a
first movie I ever saw in the theaters
so that was like a transcending
experiencing that film because I just I
would every time I would see there was
like kind of you know sensational kind
of movies where they had like very
heightened realities like I would every
time I would see one of those kind of
movies I would just come home and just
be so like jacked with energy and so
like I want to be in those movies or
like you know be a part of that world
and I would get so energized and want to
like remake that movie like you know at
ten years old or something just want
like I just like I can't like quite
articulate it was like this like
sensational feeling that I got which I
think made me really attracted to always
wanted to make sort of like you know be
very attracted to cinematic sort of
storytelling and not so much like
touchy-feely sort of like you know
cinema their take on it I can love that
stuff as well but it's like I was always
very attracted to heightened realities
and cinematic kind of filmmaking yeah I
mean I mean I think I mean like horror
horror movies were definitely me talk
about monster Palooza I mean I mean
horror movies were definitely like the I
think what introduced me to movies that
was like I mean going to I mean it's a
cliche story and a lot of like Warner
buffs have the same kind of path but
like going to Blockbuster and always
like being always drawn to the horror
section because like there was something
very like the horror section was very
light it seemed like very off limits to
some kids you know because it was a very
like simple you know parents want their
kids to go to like the comedy section or
like you know go see James Bond or
whatever and or like a the new releases
which most people would always go to in
life there was something about the
horror section was really
like their poster art I think was what
really like hooked me and you know a lot
of films like didn't really deliver on
their poster art but but but there was a
handful that did that to this day is
still like there are scenes in those I
mean you look at the films like you know
a lot of these films are not like you
know extraordinary cinema but like there
are there's there's like a soul behind
them that there was like a there was
tonal things about them and there were
scenes and moments that still are burned
into my brain things I saw when I was
like 9 or 10 years old and like scenes
that some of these movies I still watch
today I mean like these movies are just
like really kind of define my outlook on
the the world from like a horror angle I
guess and you know films that sort of
had this um you know I mean just like me
I was really obsessed with like the
horror franchises and I loved that was I
got really analytical about sequels and
like I got really like weird about
things about like oh I think you know
never Elm Street 4 is better than nine
random Street well you know all these
like really we got very analytical about
it and but it's like a fried 13th
franchise and my child's play and
Hellraiser I mean all those franchises I
just like blew through all of them I
just loved franchises and I just watched
all of them all the time and at a
certain point my mother and father that
were so not into those kind of movies at
all like they hated those kind of hated
that I was constantly renting those
movies all the time they just felt very
concerned about that and my mother is a
very kind of like you know kind of
overprotective kind of personality and
she was um she was concerned that um
that I thought I was gonna like you know
it was like doing something maybe to my
psyche maybe I you know because I was
why I was consuming so many of these
movies because they were like you know
the people forget like the early Friday
our teen movies were really dark like
they were really like very like
mean-spirited and really like brutal
like and they were not filmed there like
a typical ten-year-old would be a
consuming on a daily basis and so I then
my father got me hooked on James Bond
movies because I think around this time
like Goldeneye and Tomorrow Never Dies
had come out in the theaters like within
a couple years apart and I just like
loved was there was like probably first
demons my own movies I'd seen and I just
like loved those movies so much and
those two ones and and so that my dad
started like oh we got to go back to
like the originals and and you know go
max like a Sean Connery's and then
watching like doctor no and foremost and
like I just literally like every every
time I would return another James Bond
movie I would rent the next one and then
the next
and I was going on and then by the
certain point I've just seen all of them
and all the way to like you know just
living daylights and license kill em
like they were just um and that then
they during that time I was like
obsessed with action movies and I was
like watching all these action movies
and I loved like Steven Seagal movies
and Jean clubs like sudden impact and
all these like John Kong or sudden death
sorry and all this like jean-claude van
damme I mean all these like kind of late
80s early 90s action movies and then
I'll get bored with that and I would be
like obsessed with like slapstick
comedies and like Jerry Zucker and top
secret and Naked Gun wrongfully accused
and spy hard and all that stuff and then
and I think like as I started to you
know get older I start to be like more
attracted to I guess like started to
embrace more like you know like some
international films and started like you
know learn about like her Sawa and and
some just uzuki and jean-pierre melville
and Truffaut and all these all these
different directors they were doing some
extraordinary things in different
countries and just sort of seeing it
from that point of view and so I mean
like there was a time that I was just
like throughout my early 20s and late T
I was just kind of like you know and
throughout my teens and tweens I guess I
was just consuming everything you know
like I mean I'm just consuming
everything and and I just um you have a
like but I think like but genre has
always been like the kind of I've always
been attracted to sort of like like I
was saying earlier like so it was
attractive like sensational kind of
storytelling like grounded but like but
but I I love grounded characters inside
of a story that gets more and more wild
like the goes to wilder and Wilder
dimensions like I just love movies they
keep on piling on top of itself like I
like that almost like a like a video
game kind of structure like I'm really
interested in where it's like the movie
just keeps on going to like a level 2
level 2 level and it just keeps on
escalating like that's the kind of
structure and kind of like pace that I
like in movies that's sort of what a lot
of the movies that grew up watching
we're kind of like that where they just
keep don getting even if they were
risking being too ridiculous they didn't
care like I just like Australian
exploitation movies I was a big fan of
because those new he's just like for
better for worse they just kind of like
went all the way with everything and
they were just like kind of candy
concepts but they were taken very very
seriously with really good acting too
like they had really great actors and
and they just
like when into another dimension by the
third act and like that's that's always
been the kind of storytelling that I've
been really attracted to just really
like relentless kind of entertainments
and just kind of like it's like movies
you only have a certain amount of time
to like give that impact so it's like
don't waste any minute just just
jam-packed it like there's no like just
jam pack it with as much like
entertainment as possible and my people
think like oh well the final five
minutes is really entertaining but like
we got to get it's like just make the
most like fun entertaining wild
experience that you could possibly make
you know like that's so I've just been
always attracted to like entertainment
in movies like that's that's that's I
think the most important part first and
foremost yeah you were saying about how
most parents would be worried about
their children watching horror what I
was so fascinated by was how nice the
people were at monster Palooza
oh yeah and we've been to a lot of la
film events and I mean the people were
super respectful not just the staff I
mean the actual horror fans oh yeah so
it's interesting what do you think it is
about the horror genre that attracts
those fans and and what's sort of the
distinction between those and maybe
arthouse cinema fans or well I think
well I think I think why people that
love horror movies are like very genuine
people very loyal people's because like
they're consuming so much like darkness
I guess they're consuming so much like
extremities inside of horror movies that
like that's enough for them where they
like they they they're almost like
purging them so I think like a lot of
like like some of the nicest people like
I even like Wes Craven Sony who's like
such nice Pleasant people that make
these incredibly dark cynical movies you
know and like I think they're they're
getting it out and like whether it's
making it or watching it I think they're
um consuming a lot of that but I think
that's like that's like their fix that
they're getting it's almost like a drug
I think that's why I think it kind of
dictates their personality a little bit
maybe and then like the people they're
like the biggest pricks or the ones that
make like the night like the happiest
family movies I felt I've realized I
mean but I mean the I mean label a hard
house I mean like I mean I love all I
love all sorts of movies any light but
our house I mean like that there is sort
of like this really obnoxious
pretension that like I just not I just
don't subscribe to I'm just not I'm just
like not I'm just not a fan of it like
like a lot of you know it's like people
that are very feel like they're almost
like above it I feel like they're almost
like above certain kinds of like
exploitation movies are sort and like
you know like B movies even though 100
million block down our blockbuster
movies were considered to be B movies
these days I mean like B movie doesn't
even exist anymore but I mean like I
think a lot of people are just just so
snobbish and then like sometimes people
think that like almost not would like
movies and all that but it's like I'm so
much about the movies that most people
are snobs about not liking so it's like
I I can I can be a snap about those kind
of movies I feel you know but but I mean
like just say you know it's I I there's
so many art house films that I love I
mean like I love the art house John I
mean like you know I think Drive was I
mean Drive was such an incredible
example of like art house and commercial
genre working so effortlessly I thought
and and I thought that movie was just
brilliant and and I was like is like it
can work really well I mean like cuz
like that's I am sort of attract I'm
much more attracted to a film like drive
than perhaps maybe like fast and furious
I mean like drive is much more my kind
of like action movie because I think it
just has like art house can really work
inside of genre because like you they
sort of like spread the action out so
it's like more impactful where where's
like these other movies they're just
like they got almost like too much money
so they're just having like explosion
after explosion after explosion it's
like you know something's movies are
just like too big you know you can't
like relate to anything but yeah I mean
like I I don't know I mean like the I I
think Horrors like I mean it's never
gonna go away
I mean it's not it's it's been I mean
not to I mean I was like 1922 I mean I
was late it's been I mean horror I mean
Horrors like been around since like the
dawn of movies almost and and and it's I
mean it's it's probably the most like
it's perhaps like well the most like
like the most profitable onra out there
I mean like what's certainly one of the
most and like it's it's one of few
genres that truly gets people to a
theater that do much better in theaters
than like on DVD or like on VOD I mean
most of them did I think and
and there's just something about or it's
like it's the it's watching something
that you're not supposed to be watching
it's like a forbidden sort of it's
almost like um a roller coaster kind of
like like a like a ride where like
you're it's it's a safe ride but it's
still you know kind of like could be a
very like shocking and and then and and
going going to a haunted house kind of
feel to it and that's why I just think
horror movies are just like there's
nothing better than going to see like
remember when I saw like the remake of
like The Hills Have Eyes back in like
2006 and just like blew my head off like
I was like this is like such a ballsy
mainstream you know big like hefty
budget movie but like made by this crazy
French director that just like was
complete like came from these really
shocking movies and France and like got
that got the job to make one of these
like big mainstream or disguised as a
mainstream movie but it just got away
with some very bold stuff in it and
watching that movie in a multiplex like
it's like you're weren't supposed to be
watching it like that that's the kind of
like I mean like Paul Verhoeven's like
when my idols and he did like Robocop
and showgirls and all that and starship
troopers and and I think he's um he's
like a career that I sort of like and
really fascinated by I'm sort of like
almost like one a model after sort of
like as a goal because like he what he
was he what he was able to do is that I
mean he was able to he makes these very
mainstream movies that are that are
clothed to be very mainstream and all
that but but he's able to his films are
also very politically incorrect his
films are very bold his films are very
young I mean like Starship Troopers is
like a 100 million dollar fascist
fantasy monster movie and like you just
get to know everybody in the first hour
of the movie then he just like Lido
lates all of them in five minutes and
like it's just I mean like that that
that kind of like boldness but inside of
like mainstream storytelling like I mean
I think Kingsman like the first Kingsman
it came out a few years ago I thought
that was like kind of like a throwback
to that kind of movie cuz that movie was
like I love that movie I was like like
that was a very bold movie on a lot of
levels but it was like you know into our
budget like some of the things they got
away with him at movie it was like not a
typical kind of it wasn't a hundred
percent what they I mean it wasn't it
wasn't what they mark
like when people saw there's like
certain things in there there were very
divisive very polarizing to people but
overall it's like a fun movie but
there's like those certain scenes that I
might want out of a that's gonna be a
little divisive on some people I'm like
that's like that's always been I've
always been a track I've always been
attracted to like almost like
infiltrating the mainstream like I think
like that's like what I'm really I track
because I love straightforward story
I love mainstream movies like I love
commercial kind of movies but but sort
of like injecting a you know a boldness
inside of it because I think like
infiltrating the mainstream is when you
can like really like do some like damage
you know like in a good way
you know yeah but yeah yeah I think yeah
yeah that's a yeah but but yeah I mean
like that's yeah I mean like those kind
of those that just like you know just
sensational kind of movies or I think
because movies are all about like just
like I think entertain me in the
beginning like that's like the first
deformers you always have to like
entertain and then if you're hopefully
can have like a bold statement
underneath it like that's I think what's
always even more attractive to like have
a statement that's suggesting something
about the world that we're living in or
like the generation that we're living in
right now I think those are the kind of
movies that I think overall very tragedy
films you know like um like I don't know
if there's like this film called
unfriended that came out it hasn't like
a Skype horror movie which cover I know
a couple people thought they liked it
ripped off like another movie but I I
just was looking at that film and I felt
like that was such a brilliant like home
run of a move Annie I know some people
didn't like it and because like they
hate movies that take place on a Skype
and all that but it's like that's the
generation we're living in right now so
it's like what else are they gonna do I
mean like and and and I just thought it
was so I don't think people like realize
like how well-made that movie was like
the editing just the details gives us
all through Skype it was like for Skype
cameras and like it was relevant it was
about like this girl that killed herself
and she's like haunting them and like
through the computers and and and it was
it was relevant about like bullying and
and and and teen suicide but it was also
like just also at the same time like
this like straight down the middle like
80 for a minute teen slasher
supernaturals the slasher film and and
and it was just like it was one of the
most purest teen slasher movies I had
ever seen and like the fact that we're
still having because everyone's trying
to be so like overly clever with like
horror movies and leg and I understand
that light but sometimes I think if like
things are a little too everyone's
trying to be like like scream or
something you know which is a you know
extraordinary film but like but I think
everyone's try always trying to do do
that again like like they they're always
trying to make their movie so I think
overly smart for their own good
sometimes and and I just think like I
wish horror films were a little bit more
like I think a 24 is brilliant like I
mean a 24 like with like the witch and
green room and and like the monster and
this movie hereditary coming out in June
which looks incredible and like there's
movies they're just like they're not
they're not really trying to be anything
more than they are but they're still
like this like weight behind them that
makes them feel like they're bigger than
what they are and and yeah I just like
that sort of like stripped-down simple
storytelling and nothing a 24 is really
like excelling at that and they're not
trying to be like oh really clever you
know they're just lay had a concept and
they just play it so well with like very
serious dramatic actors and but they're
very commercial kind of genre concepts
that they play and most of them but yeah
I mean that's know so in reading your
bio you were an actor for a while yeah I
was um I mean I start like I started
like around since birth I started would
like filming anyway that's what I really
wanted to do I was always making things
all the time just filming everything but
this camera that my parents got me all
the time but then eventually I started
to um because I didn't really have I
mean I had a lot of friends that are
kind of like forced to be in the movie
but they were just not great and so I
felt like okay well the only person that
cares the most about this is me so I'm
just going to I'm just gonna put myself
in them and and I started to put myself
in them in their through that I started
to like get a knack for like being you
know I really like doing comedy like I
really like kind of being like the
Entertainer like a funny guy in the room
and doing impressions and just being you
know served like um you know I could
sort like a Jack Black kind of kind of
thing I just really liked kind of over
the top kind of like comedic acting and
just kind of had a very weird sense of
humor like since grammar school just had
a very everyone kind of saw the world
this way and I kind of saw the world
this way and it was just a very um I
just had a very kind of like off-kilter
door bizarre sense of humor and the way
I saw the world and a lot of levels so
that and then like but I didn't like
actually start pursuing or like actually
getting somewhat serious about acting
until I was like a freshman in high
school and then I decided to audition
for like the musical ones like they had
- go do like a musical I'm gonna play
every year and and they didn't like they
did hello da like that year and I just
all different for them you know and got
like a part is like a featured extras
like this like shoemaker part and it was
like this like just like a little little
gag that I had with this leg woman who
was like you know super super tall and
it was like you know like a fun little
visual gag and and then and then after
that and then the next year I was like
okay now I'm actually gonna start
auditioning you know for like both to
play music oh I'm gonna take this
seriously and I well I I guess I didn't
all this able to play that year because
I ended up playing football that year
which is like the worst mistake I've
ever made in my entire life but but then
I then following spring I audition for
the musical which was like anything goes
and I'm like I I didn't get it which I
was like shocked about that not even
like in the chorus and I was like really
like I was like really really upset
about that you know and and so I ended
up taking acting classes this little
acting class right outside of my town
and and that started like really like
okay like let me like really like honed
because that really hit me hard that I
didn't get accepted that musical so I
just like wants you like really like
take this very seriously and then in the
following year then I started like I
just like get get you know the rise to
fame like in high school and started to
get like bigger and bigger roles and did
like into the woods and played the wolf
and did like this path all practically
and and did and then my senior year I
did like this play called you can't take
it with you and that was like a Lionel
Barrymore film from 1939 and uh playing
his part I played like the grandpa and
it was it was like you know it's like
the star making a performance in high
school you know
and I feel like I arrived in high school
at that time and and then and then to
the following musical and then after
that by that point I was like I've known
is like the actor like no one really
everyone knew that I was like obsessed
with movies but no one really took me
seriously it's like filmmaker just as
like an actor man leave it love movies
and and then after that I studied at the
American Academy Dramatic Arts in New
York for a few months and that was like
a really really intense experience with
the teachers and just a very um you know
it's like you get no like gold stars no
matter what you came for you enter there
and like they're just very very brutal
on you and it was a very like political
very cutthroat kind of experience the
good experience over on me there's some
people that I still talk to to this day
that I met there so that was like a you
know still wonderful experience in
longer and really kind like breaks you
down and trains you pretty hard for like
the real world of everything and and
then after that I just sort of like hit
the grinds you know did a lot black box
theater someplace where you know quasi
successful some plays were not at all
but it was just like you know constantly
you know consoling acting you know like
this chances to act and play different
characters and um but I mean as far as
like transitioning to this like
prestigious acting school in New York
that like Robert Redford went to and
Grace Kelly and Dana Vito all these guys
and Paul Rudd and it was like you know I
cuz in high school it's like I mean yeah
I marry like my dad was like one of the
first people that really like made that
reality check to me um telling me that
like you know I mean like I you know
it's like I think it's really great the
stuff you're doing and it's in a school
and all that like but you know at the
end of day it's like you're a big fish
in a puddle you know and like that's and
you didn't really use those words but he
might as well have said that and and
then when I transitioned to the acting
school actually it was I mean I
eventually you know because like I think
everyone was like trying to make their
name and that school as well and I think
that was like because everyone could you
go in there it's like it's quite
intimidating because like everyone is
there for the exact same reason everyone
takes it just as seriously as you
everyone has you know you always think
everyone's better than you everyone has
better looks than you everyone's gonna
be more successful than you and there's
like just constant jealousy and all that
stuff and and a lot of depression a lot
of breakdowns and all this because you
never think that you're good enough
because you're never being told that
ever
and that's not their job to tell you
that and you know so but but you know I
eventually you know I kind of found a
loophole to sort of like say you know to
is somewhat make a name for myself in
that school as well and and it was like
a theatre history presentation that we
all do in front of the class and I did
like I just sort of like um did like an
impression of the actual teacher that
taught the class and like that was like
that was sort of like the time to like
you know that that like what made like a
lot of students like like no like I
guess Know Who I was in that school or
like we're like so you know not look at
me as some like weird quiet kid you know
because but um but yes so like event so
it's all bad just like you know it's all
about just trying to make a name for
yourself like every every spot you go to
and trying to stand out as much as
possible and trying to find a way trying
to find a loophole to get there
and so I mean but yeah I mean like after
that I mean I'm just like doing a lot of
them acting in New York City and and and
a couple plays upstate New York a little
bit and and then I think I was like
around like 20
I started making like 20 long 22 I
started to like actually start making
some shorts I'm at they all I mean the
first short I made was like this it's on
YouTube it's like this movie called
quiet on the set and I was like sort of
like a Christopher Guest kind of like
mockumentary type and I mean it looks
like terrible I mean the production
quality was terrible I mean was shot
like um but it's like I mean I I mean
like it's you know the first step is a
little rough renovated bad I mean I
still to this day thing is pretty fun
and it's a funny movie like it but like
but I just like you know just I got a
lot of like actor friends mine and like
you know it was like based on this like
crazy theatre director that I'd worked
with who was like just like I'm nut job
and I just like played a version of
Hannibal and and you know it's like that
was like the first movie that I made
from beginning to end and and then you
know I try to do like these you know I
try to do like a sketch show and the c2
channel called like sunbae DS which like
he's like really it was like very you
know ordinary situations like jacked up
to extremities and it was a very like
serve like inspired by Teletubbies like
that son baby and like it was just a
very very weird since a humorous orb
like eastbound and down kind of humor
and and then that was like not
successful at all and
and then made one more short and then
people started respond to that one and
then I was like oh well maybe I should
like actually pursue maybe I should just
drop acting exam III feel all these
shorts now making they don't look very
good and like because I'm putting myself
in them and I can't concentrate unlike
the actual quality of the movie because
I'm just doing this for me as an actor
and I did really cares that I mean I
tried some low camera tricks and try to
like you know try to experiment some
things but I was just so consumed like
the acting part of it and they were just
purely for exposure but no one was gonna
really take them seriously because like
they just look terrible I mean if that
quants that thing I mean I shot that on
a V X 1000 camera that I got for free at
some like internship that I did and it
has from like 1999 that camera and just
like 2008-2009 I was making this thing
and I and everyone everyone else is like
shooting on like the red ethics at that
time and my I was like so bitter that
like and all my stuff looked like just
looked horrible and like their stuff at
the time looks so polished you know and
I just didn't really think anyone's
gonna take me seriously so I just um I
was like 2011 was when I started to just
decide to like pursue directing but I
didn't want to go to film school at that
time so I just just hit up a friend that
I went to high school with who's doing a
lot of extras coordinating for like curb
enthusiasm and all these different shows
and and and she was doing much better
than I was at the time and so I just
reached out to her blindly and just said
you know is there any opportunity for
any production assistant work or
anything like that
and she got me a job as a production
assistant on this kind of small wait a
little under a million dollar art film
and shot all around New York City and
upstate New York as well like I was like
five weeks sort of like the whole that
was the first time I really learned like
you know 14 15 hour days sometimes
18-hour days six days a week you know I
was late I was I was you know I was
actually living in New Jersey at that
time so I was like taking the train
every morning and Wow and desperate that
was gonna miss the last train or
whatever and you know so like that that
really that really like train me a lot
like because they put me in the grip
Department they put me in the camera
Department like really learning how
movies were made and then after that I
just like did a lot of freelancing a lot
of other sets as well and did a lot of
production assisting throughout New York
and then
and then I met a friend I met someone on
one of the SATs who was interested in
producing and he had a camera and and I
we were big movie buffs and and I was
interested in making this I want to make
my first like proper short film and it
was like this short he's like this black
and white sorta like neo-noir kind like
Blood Simple a little bit it's not like
three simultaneous stories that are
taking place at this tavern in New
Jersey and and and you know that was
like the first proper short that I made
and that's like what really kind of like
taught me how to like properly make a
film I was working with like a real
cinematographer and all these like kinda
like a lot of these students from the
Art Institute of New York City that I
was meeting with and be kind of it was a
lot of people from that from that school
and and then and then I finished that
and like a week later I just like drove
out to LA and like I had no plan I mean
like I just I I had been talking about
moving to LA for years and all the way
back to like 2008 I was talking about
moving out there and just like every
year I was constantly finding an excuse
to hold me back and and but now I'm just
like and I just got it like just bite
the bullet and just do it and and yeah
and I had that short film is sort of
like a calling card a little bit and you
know that have played it like a college
Film Festival and sort of like snuck
that in because I didn't go to a college
and I made a lot of people through that
school and some people I still work with
to this day and and there were a lot of
like I'm becoming DPS and camera people
and editors know that and and then just
like over and then over the next like
three years or so I was just like
networking a lot just make just cranking
out as many just being as creative as
possible every year just showing my
stuff to normal people and you know then
eventually I made them my first feature
drifter may been 2015 I mean I was like
I just made that movie I was just like
in a very like I was just in a very like
gruesome state of mind of just I was
getting very aggravated or like every
short I was making just was going they
just they just weren't getting me to
where I wanted them to be and but they
were training me so much and they were
like really um making me um learn about
like what it was I'd offer to movies
like what my aesthetic was and I learned
how to like you know what my point of
view on the world was and like the
thematics that I that I
like than the kind of tone that I liked
and and and then with drifter I just um
I just made that movie out of pure like
frustration and a lot of extreme anger
towards just I was I was very like like
self-hating and very like just really
just I just just there was a lot of like
hate in my brain all the time during
that time I was it was a very like very
like upsetting state of mind but I was
then I just didn't like that feeling so
I thought like well I think the only way
to sort of get out of this feeling of
sort of like just translated cinematic
way and sort of get all that nihilism
and all that sort of almost like purging
myself and sort of like almost like a
form of like therapy and and make it
make it like make him like the angriest
movie I could possibly make and and
almost like that movie it was almost
like I liked the intent I mean it sounds
really obnoxious to say this but like
the intention of that movie I was like I
was like trying to hurt the audience
like I was trying to like like I was
trying to like it's like I I wanted to
be I wanted to be like like like like
like like a very uncomfortable painful
experience I don't want it to almost be
like not like a typical movie like I
want I want it to be like this um just
sort of like faint like this relentless
thing that's keeping its consi trying to
like attack like that's like I don't
like an assault on all senses and like
that that was like being tension and
like it was it was very much like extras
like exercising a lot of them you know
demons and you know some people called
it like like a cult exercise and
violence and and and I think that i
don't i don't think that's incorrect i
mean i think it kind of was I mean it
was that particular movie was very much
like the point of view was just like
let's just completely remove like any
sort of ounce of because it's a very
that died movie was intended to be like
sort of like this really messed up sore
like soulless kind of experience where
was like I'm just just reflecting the
extremities of like the society that
we're living in and it was a very
pessimistic and I remember like one
review said it was like like like this
weird sight like relevance as being this
like weird zeitgeist for like the
American despair and pessimism I was
like wow that's it's pretty live let's
breathe that's pretty interesting I mean
like that's because I can't say that
person's not
true I mean looking back at it now it's
like that that was maybe it was very I
wasn't specifically thinking about that
when I was making because I was just
consumed in just making the Moody itself
but like that was definitely the back of
my head because I was just a very um I
was an extremely pessimistic person when
I was making that movie it was like not
healthy at all and um and so I just had
to like get that on my system cuz I just
you know I just I just I just wanted to
get that movie out of my system so I
don't have to make that kind of movie
again because I had that you know I'm
proud of it things about that movie be
like I mean it also kind of like you
know it almost sometimes like troubles
me when I watch it because I know what
my mind was when I was making in I just
I don't really like that person that was
there was doing that because that this
wasn't a very um I wasn't very like
healthy state of mine and that's not
it's not really like I just don't want
to make a film that nihilistic again
yeah like that's but but I think that
was just the time to do that you know if
I was gonna do it I did it was just I
just want to make a very anxious know
there like just something that was just
like you know like pay attention to me
and like that's like that sort of that
was like the intention of just like just
trying to be like the loudest most
brashest you know just most like
aggressive movie that I could possibly
and make at that time and was like that
was always the intention yeah I like
what you said about how you when you
watch drifter you see that's where you
were at that time and maybe whether it
makes you uncomfortable or not you you
see who you were and what you were going
through what you were trying to intend
audience to feel and you hear it with
bands like like let's say you to their
first two albums very angry excellent
albums but different from newer ones
where you know life is maybe a little
better money is more plentiful so so I
think people are in a different state of
mind yeah but but I get it I was
watching this um talk show with Wes
Craven and I think was from like 1988 oh
my god and it had some of the
commercials still playing Oh from that
time and this was from like a talk show
that I watched as a little girl and I
was like wow even the tone of the
commercials were more upbeat the music
everything was different
so the tonality of the world was
different than yeah so I think we we
reflect what you know and if you're
saying it 2015 people have come out of
the recession yeah it was a tough time
everybody especially Millennials because
jobs were not what you know it was a
tough time for everybody I get that you
could have felt that it was it was an
angry time for a lot of people yeah I
mean I I think I was just like really
attracted to you know exposing just like
the ugliness of humanity and just like
the flip side of things you know like
serve Bret Easton Ellis kind of like you
know I mean how he would like when he
wrote like rules of attraction American
Psycho and all he's like he was much
more attracted to like the the the flaws
and people and I think and I'm oh you
know I think the one thing that I am
very attracted to is very coming a
common thing that no matter how
mainstream I would want to dabble in
like I am very interested like very
flawed people and like very flawed
characters against even more flawed
characters and sort of like um kind of
like you know somewhat cynical outlook
on the world but like in a fun in a fun
exciting way like not like in a you know
in a kind of like a witty entertaining
kind of way and but I think I'm getting
better about about approaching it in
doing the same kind of intention but
doing it a little bit more I mean
lighter is not the best kind of we're
just a little bit more like audience
friendly but still having that same kind
of outlook you know because I don't want
to I don't want to lose that kind of
outlooks I think that's what what makes
you know my stuff kind of like you know
specific but but just doing it a little
more like you know a little more
something that like maybe my mom would
enjoy you know I mean if there's not her
kind of a she's with drifter I'm not
sure if you're able to talk about the
budget and and some of that but I was
curious about how you do the location
scouting cuz you talked about the desert
yeah and how you were very intrigued by
the desert and I know the deserts always
intrigued me that there's something
frightening about it and then there's a
very mysterious and ethereal about it
because you could kind of get lost in
there and that there's all these sort of
interesting drifters and you know there
really are yeah and and you kind of
wonder what their their background is so
what is it about the desert and how did
you find that location why just like the
budget thing well we shot the movie for
like 40,000 he was like under for the
ground so like like but we shot a lot of
IED shots and I tried a couple shorts
like in Lancaster
palm down like so I kind of like well
familiar with that area and drifter was
sorta like the first time to really
embrace my like fascination with the
desert because I've been really
fascinated by it for a couple years and
cuz I love stories about isolation and
and yeah I mean like it was just like
you know just getting old before your
time and just like burning so much gas
money just driving out to the outskirts
of because you know there was no
location manager or anything there was
like very skeleton crew at like the
bare-bones operation with a movie in
like and just dry and and and but the
kicking off point was like my
cinematographer had known about the town
like that was in Bombay Beach and you
know we you know like the the bad batch
the the movie Keanu Reeves up there a
couple years ago like they had wrapped
filming a few months before we arrived
so they had an eye but I think mostly
they do like photo shoots and
commercials there and they don't do that
many features and maybe they're starting
to but but we you know like that was
like you know like we like that was the
kicking off point to write a script
around access to that town and then um
and then just driving around all over
the place trying to find it was actually
really since there was no location
measure and that movie was so it was so
much that movie is so much driven by the
set theses that like the locations need
me they were paramount in that story and
like if the locations just didn't fit
and Emily was gonna get laughed off the
screen and like and I've seen a lot of
like really low budget post-punk Obagi
post-book post-apocalyptic stories and
like shooting in like Vasquez rocks and
like lenses you see like tourists in the
back you know it's like I want to shoot
a places like no one shoots you know
like dude hit like forbidden places
almost and devils punchbowl yeah I love
that stuff I mean I want to go all the
way to like Death Valley it was way too
far and but I mean yeah me just like
finding all these like different places
and yeah it was like it was a I mean we
were in pre-production for a long time
because I just like there was like you
know they're very very small a you know
crew so it's like I could I needed I
needed time to get all that stuff you
know and and the locations were like the
major thing that was probably the most
leg because you know you don't want to
break the bank but you don't you want to
make sure the locations are as cinematic
you can get so it's like a lot of like
you know negotiating and
shooting you know and random spots all
over the place and and but yeah it was
mainly yeah I was like all around like
Lancaster Joshua Tree bomb abh
Victorville like all those and we shot a
little in LA and like shy like inside
this like haunted house which was a
oddly enough like a right around the
corner where I lived it was like I've
been trying to find that location for
like forever
and like I'd gone all these houses that
were like there there were like just
know what they like you know they're
just normal houses you know and then
they would not was not at all like I was
trying to look for like like a haunted
kind of manner like like the tales in
the Crypt kind of house or something you
know like and you know and I was shocked
that we were able to get the house that
we got because the guy was just like a
super nice guy and just totally hooked
us up with a great deal on it and and
and it was just like when I saw the
house I was like cuz I just get so
obsessive I loved locations and I loved
like the bigger the better and like you
know I just I like seeing that house I
was like and in fact it was right around
the corner like right under my nose this
entire took for like months I was trying
to find that place um I saw this place I
was like this is the this is hurt has
literally everything we needed all the
rooms like they had extra furniture I
mean like literally everything we need
it was there it was like it was almost
like - it was very odd it was they just
late it was like destiny it was really
really great but yeah I mean the
locations that's like one of the major
like that's like the one of the major
things that I'm very very like stubborn
about in pre-production because you know
dictates the quality of the movie and
like and if you I've seen films so I'd
really like crappy locations and they're
just like why would you ever use that
and and I think um you know I mean you
don't want to be like you got to be you
know realistic at a certain point but
but you know you don't there's a
difference between being realistic and
like settling why you don't want to like
say I mean you you really want to make
sure that you can get like the the best
location you can possibly yeah I mean
lie
and I think a lot people just are like
that's fine let's just shoot there it's
still a cool we'll just shoot around it
like you know I just its locations are
so so important so important I mean if
you're making a cinematic kind of story
it's like they're they're very very
important because they just like I mean
it just it just dictates so many things
you know how did you deal with the wind
and the heat and also to I don't know
how close were any any types of stores
or whatever like so how are you dealing
with the remote location and some of the
elements I mean like will will be shun
the we shot like to filming blocks in
July and August of 2015 in July we were
shooting a lot of night stuff in
Lancaster and Victor fill area and it
was like freezing yeah it was we have
this like one girl it was like she was
like covered in fake blood for like
hours that night and she was just like
shivering me and say like her teeth were
chattering the entire time it was like
it was rough but like um but but yeah
but but that wasn't that was no nothing
compared to when we shot in the town
because the Film Commission I never like
meeting with them they were like
laughing at us because we were shooting
in August like they were like even that
movie like even though I think that I
don't really I was talking about like
they they didn't they film that like
April like and even then it's hot out
there and it doesn't start to cool until
October and we couldn't push the October
I just wasn't gonna be one of those guys
that like shoots you know on the weekend
and months later shoots again I just too
impatient for that and and so yeah I
mean we shot like in the thick of the
August like literally the worst time
that you're supposed to be filming there
and I mare there was like we were so
cost if we could like afford a medic to
come out cuz we needed a matter to come
out but we're never stat we good for and
then we finally did get one to come out
and and there were yeah there are a
couple people that almost like there
couple moments people almost passed out
and like it was just uh I mean like it
was it was a it was very intense it was
like I'd never felt heat like that
before an amber when we first arrived
everyone was like having a great time I
driving out there and like the moment we
first arrived people like couldn't
breathe when they stepped out a car and
because like the moment we arrived we
went right into filming and and like
people were just like all
like feeling and we had like four more
much more ambitious days after that so
it was like I think that hottest guy was
probably 120 I think like and it was
like the biggest day too that it was
like the hottest day as well it was the
most ambitious than like but I think you
know looking back at it I think it
really dictated like people's
performances like I think it really the
freezing cold and the scorching heat I
think that really influences people
influence people's performances because
they really like all that sweat salt
real I mean all that you know I mean
just all like the sunburn and all that
all that all that stuff's real and um so
I mean like that that that's you know
cuz that you know I I just love the
stories of like the original Texas
Chainsaw Massacre how it was like
scorching heat or just like such a nasty
atmosphere and world they were filming
or locations they were filming and so
like I kind of like you don't wanna
touch anything but it's just like you
look at the film and it's like and it
lends itself very well to it you know
Chris I wanted to hear about you taking
this week-long drive across I was like
four or five days out okay so you said
you didn't totally plan it out to come
to LA you've been thinking about it for
a long time ya know I've been thinking
about it since I mean like since I
graduated high school I mean like I've
been wanting without therefore acting at
the time and then yeah but like I mean
at a certain point I was like you know
what I think I've done all I can do in
New York why I mean I was hardcore
wiling to pursue filmmaking at that time
and New York just wasn'ts you know so
theater driven you know and I love
theater I love like Broadway and all
that I love that stuff and I want it to
be like an actor on stage for a long
time but but wit as far as like the film
business I mean like you know there's
lost up at film at the shoot out there
but like you know la is just like you
know it's just a it this is like it's
like the capital of hot it's the capital
of movies you know it's like it's just
like and so I just I you know I just
thought it like you know I just I just
got to stop I just got do it you know
and and
yeah I mean like it really you know it's
very I mean IIIi recommend it to a lot I
mean a lot people like I like fly their
cars out or something you know I mean I
I know yeah I mean I'd like to like
Oklahoma and like New Mexico and stay in
it you know stay you know things like
really like cheap motels and he's like
weird plague you know all these
Scottsdale Arizona and got to like see
all these places and be real life
drifters sorry um probably I mean it was
like it wasn't well I mean I'm sure I
mean III came across some weird people
yeah I mean just in different just
corners of the town and like it was just
but yeah I mean III definitely recommend
it I mean IIIi love the experience and
then it was a very um I mean I hated
like pulling over for gas or like
pulling over till I use the restroom
because I just love to keep moving going
and and but ya know it was it was a
really light very transcending very like
therapeutic experience cuz you know
you're just not thinking about what's
ahead of you just yet you're not you
don't think about the past at all and
it's such like in the moment kind of
thing and and yeah I me always yeah was
grant everyone the best experience in my
life driving out to LA actually yeah I
loved David just like totally you know
you're just not thinking about anything
at that time it's like well there's rare
moments where you just like you know
there's nothing to really hardcore think
about just yet like in that in that very
tiny amount of time and you're just sort
of like going moment to moment and and
then then you move to LA and then you're
like oh god now I gotta like it back to
them you know reality you know and and
then it gets like gruesome but but like
that yeah but like that that brief
amount of time was great you know I
loved it no were there things leading up
to that moment when you said okay I
think now is the time you were 24 yeah I
think make I think making that short
probably and then like then when I got I
think I never I was thinking about I was
like am I gonna should i not make this
short and just moved out to LA blindly
or should I wait a few more months make
this short and then move out to LA and I
bad that felt like the best about to do
something like that because I didn't to
go out there with literally nothing and
so I just like Navis Shore and and and
then
you know we screened it at this place
called the producers Club in New York
City which is like on 44th Street it's
like a little black box they do allow
like rehearsals and plays there and but
they also do some like screenings and
like they like a projector that you can
get and you know like I mean like 70
people came to it so it was really you
know it's a nice little turnout for that
and like they responded to it very well
and so is it like that kind of boosted
up your confidence and then you go to LA
and you're all your confidence energy go
was just shattered with every day when
every ever every day brutal but like I
mean but yeah I mean like it was yeah I
mean III yeah I think I think yeah I
think was good to have like that short
film like in the in my back pocket
because that helped me like meet other
people for later for other shorts and
that they like they could take me
somewhat seriously that I did I you know
but I'm not a total idiot that I can
make movies no and and then I just
started to make more and more shorts
with more people that I was meeting out
here and you know just honing the craft
and and and and learning you know just
about the nuts and bolts of movies and
you know yeah was there a moment that
you thought about turning the car around
um no no it was it was a pretty like it
is pretty light just like straight shoot
just like this is no turning back I mean
like it's like I just I don't know I
mean I just I was just in that point in
my life where it's like there's nothing
there's there's nothing more for me to
do out in New York and there's just like
nothing like I know what I want to do
right now like I know this new path I
want to take and New York's just not
gonna do it for me you know and and if I
if I'm serious about this when I'm
serious about pursuing directing and
wanting to be a writer director than
I've been I have to I have to move to
Los Angeles and I know the first well
the first things I went to when I moved
out to LA I went to like the screening
of slitter which was like a James James
Gunn's movie like one of his like really
man they played it I went to the arrow
theater was the first time I went there
and James guy was there for a Q&A the
first thing that came out his mouth was
like you have to move to Los Angeles and
I was like well it's been validated now
I feel now I feel good about this but ya
know I mean like yeah I mean like I know
a lot of some people like you know we
live in Toronto and
like to film in New York and all that
and there's I guess work all over the
place but but I mean la just like the
heart and soul of all that it's just so
much more convenient for everything and
that like all the deals are made out
here and it's just like you know it's
everyone's like in sync I mean it is
like a bubble but like it's you know
it's it's it's good to be part of that
bubble I think yeah I was wondering if
we could talk about short films for a
moment and you talked about how you made
your first short film and when you look
back at it now there's things that
you're really proud about it and and so
some of the misconceptions some of these
filmmakers have about short films and
it's just your opinion I get it it's not
law but you know you had some opinions
about it and I would love to hear about
it
yeah I mean like you know I understand
there like a lot of people um you know
are very sort of like anti short films
that they want to UM you know I get this
I hear these people saying like you know
no one cares about short films and all
that light you know I mean I mean
there's an Academy Award for short films
I mean like obviously some people care
about them but like I mean but I mean
like I I get what they're saying that
feature films I mean I mean like that
makes sense now I was making shorts for
years and none of them were going
anywhere then boom I make a feature and
then again it's like you know it gets a
lot of exposure and all that stuff so
there is I understand that but um but I
wouldn't have been able to approach the
feature the way I did if it wasn't for
all those shorts that I was making and
so I think like short films for me I
started to realize over the years that
they're not at all about getting
representation through those or getting
a big movie out of those I mean like
that that would there was a time that
that that happened I still am shocked
when people make like one five minutes
short that goes viral they get like a
twenty million dollar movie like I just
don't really understand that at all um I
think you really need to earn your
stripes a little bit um and but yeah I
mean III think shorts are much more just
about like like sculpting your aesthetic
and learning how to tell a story and
working with actors and working with
like truncated schedules and and just uh
just understanding how movies are made
before you jump into a feature because
like making a feature versus making a
short I mean it's it really is night day
actually I mean it's such a completely
different experience like you need to
you need to get there's like warm-up
periods and light and and and maybe make
shorts that are like you know five
minutes than ten minutes then maybe a 20
minutes sure like getting a little bit
closer to you know stretching out a
story a little bit more and but yeah I
mean I think like I don't know I mean I
just um you know everyone has their
theories on things and and I don't want
to like knock anything down but the I
just don't I think when people say I
don't get I don't care about shorts I
just I just want to I just graduated
film school I just want to make a
feature right now like that's I hear
that a lot from people and and or people
just want to make just one short and
then jump into a feature and I feel like
yeah I'm there like Rian Johnson said
somebody did like the newest Star Wars
movie and and he was like saying make
like 30 short films if you can like make
as many mistakes as bug because that's
that's why the biggest thing like
because I think making movies is always
like just sort of like success training
experiment mess up a lot you know just
Minoo always go for like the more like
you know ambitious projects always try
to like you know approach you know
something that's hard you know I think a
lot of people get so cautious about them
I think they're they're so afraid of
failure I think they're so afraid of
they're so terrified of like making a
movie that's maybe a little too dense or
a little too challenging for them to
approach in a you know short schedule
like no money or something and be like I
know I've always because like I mean
yeah if you make something that's like
super ambit and you and you you and
maybe maybe you do totally fail but it's
like I would rather make something
that's you know ambitious and I
challenge me so much and train me for
like the next movies and perhaps maybe
like fail at it then make something
that's so like just two people talking
to each other they're just such a you
know kind of like a kind of an easy
movie just because it's more
economically realistic maybe but that's
I don't think that's gonna like train
you like it on you know I think III
think we can train you on a somewhat of
a level but I think I think I think if
you could if you can do something really
ambitious in a very short schedule on a
very tight budget like like something
like Robert Rodriguez or like you know
John Carpenter
I mean or Edgar Wright even I mean like
those are like there's like the guys the
that I like look up to they're like
they're kind of a I understand like
Rodriguez and John Carter score their
own music and do a lot of their own
stuff but it's like but their mentality
about always going for like the more
ambitious project and making about just
creating a bunch you know because I mean
John Carpenter made so many short films
before he made like dark star and then
Rodriguez made so many short films 14:8
el Mariachi and and I just think like
short films are very important to do
because I think if you completely
neglect them you're just like I almost
think it's sort of like and I think it's
somewhat disrespectful I think to to
like moviemaking because like what makes
you think you're so good to just jump
into a feature right away and it's like
I mean I mean Scorsese made so many
shorts even before like who's that
knocking on my door I mean like so I
mean I yeah I'm very much like pro pro
short films and then make as many as
possible and just really just screw up
as much as possible like make as many
mistakes as possible you know because
it's because one day you might make that
movie where everything just clicks and
like but you're not gonna be able make
that movie until you make those previous
movies that you've learned from all
those mistakes and that's like yeah yeah
I just I just I just just don't
overthink things just keep keep creating
keep making making stuff yeah you said
something really interesting and that
was shooting two people talking is one
thing but in terms of you may not really
grow from that what do you think is
tougher adding more actors to the
production or sort of a location that's
out in the public arena and there's no
telling what could happen sometimes more
people make things much more complicated
oh yeah yes it does very much I mean
then like getting all that coverage and
all those personalities and also serve
and making sure that you're getting
enough coverage to tell the story with
all those people moving around I mean
like Jeff Darren's last this recent
feature like they were both ensemble
casts and this recent one much more so
and like that that was like you know
that I mean like it's you know it's it's
it's it's you know it's it's it's you
know it's it's tough you know it's it's
tough trick again all that coverage like
you know you just gotta like
I mean you just got a cast well and you
just gotta like almost slide just but
yeah member like John Carpenter said
something when he was like shootin a
thing because I had such an ensemble
cast a lot of people on screen at once
it's like just put the camera in the
middle and just kind of like go clock
like clockwork you know and then just
get that person get that person you know
like and but if you're like outside the
circle you're like completely screwed so
that's like I was like a nice thing but
yeah but I think shooting in a public
place I think yeah I mean like that it's
like the worst when you don't have like
permits or something or like blocking
off streets or doing you're not allowed
to do lockup so people I mean like I
mean I make it make it a movies like I
mean it's a nightmare I mean it's like
it's just I mean there's so many now
it's like there's so many and there's
there's so many I mean and whenever a
movie gets made and it's actually good
like it's like it's it's a miracle
honestly because like there's so because
people watch like the most simplistic
thing about a movie they just see the
finished product but it's like you said
I want you know try to watch as many
documentaries about the making of movies
like I just go through like this many
making out featurettes as I can just
like see what these guys were going
through or these women were going
through making these movies and and like
just you know it's I mean it's like this
you know it's like everything everything
goes wrong like all the time and like
that but that's like that's the job and
like you know that's um it's designed to
be very very difficult and but but at
the end of day it's like you're making a
move in it's like the coolest thing in
the world you're creating a world you
know it's like you're creating an
artificial universe and so I think like
but that's the but in order to design
make-believe it's like you know they're
you know you gotta eat you know I eat
some pizza you know concrete a little
bit you know and like that but that's
that's that's all part of it I mean
making movies like from pre-production
to filming at post-production you know
it's like I mean I'm just like I go
through like extreme depression
throughout eat all segments because like
you just care about it more than
anything in the world and you just want
it to be the greatest thing in the world
or the best movie you know how to make
at that time and it just means
everything to you so it's like
throughout pre-production filming and
post-production um you know at least
from my purse
like very depressed of myself because
I'm just trying to um just just trying
my hardest to get what's inside my head
on screen and and you're just battling
so so many so many things just fighting
against you but it's like but at the end
of day it's just like the only thing
that truly matters it's like what's
inside the frame you know it's like
everything around the frame no one gives
no one cares about at all like when they
watch the movie so it's like I think
that should always be in the back year
ahead because I think so many people
I feel like focus more on what's going
on around the frame they like the
presentation of being a director that
they forget what they're actually
photographing and and a yeah I think
it's always about like what's inside the
frame and nothing else matters and and
so it's like that just like extreme
focus you know I'm not directors monitor
and around the scene and you know I mean
like I think like like Stanley Kubrick
said described filmmaking which i think
is so on the money like you described
filmmaking saying like it's like reading
war and peace while in bumper cars or
whatever I was like that's that's yeah I
mean that's pretty much what it is it's
like trying to be so focused with like
all these explosions going on around you
and but but that's like you know that
but filming is my favorite part if
anything I mean a lot of people find
editing their favorite part filming is
my favorite part because I I think my
energy translates more to filming
because like editing you're like sitting
down it's like a lot of sitting you know
you're sort of like just you know the
last chance to save the movie you're so
you know it's just you and the editor
and and then you and the composer and
all that but both filming it's like I
love multitasking I love like I love
communicating to multiple people at once
and and I because I just I'm such an
anxious and patient person that I just
love to like just constantly moving
moving moving but you know like I'm
moving forward all the time and and
that's why I you know that's you know
that's you know that some you know
sometimes having a truncated or a very
tight schedule I think lends itself well
to you because you know I think perhaps
maybe if you have a really long schedule
you might people might get lazy or
something because they think oh I'll
just shoot it tomorrow
you know and say it but it's like I
think it's very sometimes very good so I
mean you don't want a super short
schedule like but like I think like the
the right balance of time where it's
like tight but it's not super tight
where it's like you know I think like
you know like 25 days or something
that's like I think that's like the
ideal or like 30 days or something like
that's like an ideal schedule for movies
but I think or maybe even 40 I don't
know but but them yeah it's almost like
a game of some sort not like Jenga but
you know you're you're trying to keep
something that wants to fall apart yeah
every moment you're trying to keep it
not from falling apart and seeing ahead
oh yeah no I mean like it's like the
moment I mean because I I mean I usually
like see the finished product before we
even start making the movie I mean I
know exactly like what this movie is
going to be and by the end of it like
but just getting there could be like
climbing Mount Everest but like you know
you just know you see exactly you hear
them you know exactly what this movie's
going today so it's like there's so many
there's so much chaos that goes on
especially like a little bunch of film
with like a short schedule there's so
much it just lends and a very ambitious
kind of material know that it lends
itself to absolute chaos just too many
people on set just to just too many
explosions and like but I think admits
and you know I miss all this chaos like
you have to always remember that like
you still need to make a good movie and
like that's no one no one cares about
like no one who's gonna pay to watch
your movie is going is is gonna care at
all about the chaos that was going on on
that day and and I you just have to
understand alike like you you still you
need to make a good movie and that's
always the end goal and like despite all
this craziness going on you just and it
and I think like sometimes when all this
chaos is going on a challenge it really
shows how much you want to make movies
because it's like because when you feel
like you're completely all alone in a
situation and like all these like crazy
things and you're the only one that
cares about this movie the most like you
need to just like have this such like it
really trains your extreme focus and how
truly focused you can be and and yeah
but I think like I think every filmmaker
needs to sort of like go through those
kind of movie is like super low budget
and very truncated schedule and
ambitious kind of story because I think
like that's the only way you're gonna
like true
learn how to make like big movies and
like really learn how like things work
you really gotta like get a baptism by
fire situation sort of I get thrown into
like the jungle you know and just just
you got you got to go like both feet in
or not at all
you know you just got to just got to do
it and and you know every morning you
know you're not really perky every
morning to wake up sometimes you want to
shoot yourself in the face when you wake
up you know it's a and but you just
gotta you know just gotta put on put on
it and put on an act and just and boost
morale and just keep on wanting to
remind people that you want to make like
an awesome moving at the end of the day
and despite all this crap going on like
you still want to make an awesome moving
you know and and if you keep that
mentality up it's like no people will
still keep moving forward and still keep
wanting to make this great despite all
the chaos going on as long as you're as
long as the director is like super super
focused in like what and the pounds to
remind people that you want to make
something great and show your passion
every day you know they'll they'll you
know they'll rise to the occasion and
then they'll keep going with you know
how important was it to to make a
feature film before you turn 30
ya know I mean it was it was very
important I mean like I mean I didn't
want to make a feature like at like at
19 I was trying to make a feature at 22
23 I was trying to make a feature
they're all different movies and then at
20 yeah at 24 I was trying to make
another feature then then 25 I spent a
year trying and now that was that one
got the farthest and you know we had a
sizzle reel that we shot we had a pitch
package we had like a business plan we
had a script you know we had a lot of
like just a lot of stuff package for
that movie but you know like that we
would have people come on they would
fall off and we just couldn't get you
know I was like a two hundred thousand
dollar account you know they probably
needed like we're only two hundred
thousand dollars it was like 25
locations a lot of more interior was
like another desert movie and I think I
took a lot of that stuff and put inside
of drifter like a lot of thematic stuff
of that movie just made it if they're a
little more cheaper a little more
accessible and but but yeah I mean I
spent like a year on that movie
throughout 2013 and the
and you know I you know a lot people you
know some people responded to the script
some people didn't
some people just didn't get it you know
because it wasn't very like plot heavy
it was very uh it was very like sort of
like a character driven story like it's
really kind of like whacked-out
cross-country story sort of like goes
from like California to Texas and like
and you know III think you know just you
know just we just add a certain point I
was like uh yeah I got I got a month I
got to drop this one and then I made a
couple shorts out of frustration it'd be
creatively stimulated and then and then
you know I was like 27 that's like when
I decided to make a just jump into it
with drifter know I was like just set
the dates I was like got locked in dates
over I'm just gonna just ban this thing
out and just just just just you know at
least I can have a movie with a feature
film runtime you know it's like I can at
least have a feature under my belt you
know you know might not be amazing but I
have a feature technically so it's like
that's that's that was just very very
important to me to make a feature film
as soon as possible you know and but
it's like there's always there's someone
out there that made that feature before
you or something you know it's like you
know stone Soderbergh was like 25 or 26
you know Scorsese that's it you know
it's like there's always always someone
out there like beat you to the punch or
something but but you know like that I I
think well you know because I spend a
lot of time acting so it's like and I
just I was focusing on that for a while
and but yeah I was it was very very
important for me to make it you know to
make a feature like before I was 30 very
important to me
did you crowd fun for Drifter uh-huh
what happened I mean just it just wasn't
you know I just wasn't successful at all
we just it was like an embarrassingly
unsuccessful but it was just like you
know I realized like I mean like it just
wasn't the kind of movie that and I may
I'll never do that stuff ever again I
mean I kind of felt really bad about
even starting that campaign I just
didn't feel like that movie lend itself
to that kind of campaign very well
because it was just all I was trying to
make was like just a really
psychologically like disturbing cannibal
movie and like and and that's not what
and we didn't have any hook like I mean
some people were like familiar with a
couple shorts that maybe like we didn't
we didn't have any
like we didn't we didn't have like a Big
John reactor attached we didn't it
wasn't based on like a video game or
like a graphic novel or anything it was
just like just was what it was and and
you know there was just no hook to it
and and and so I think like that so so
it just ended up being like just like a
lot of like yeah there were some like
side you know nice donators and all that
have like you know a lot of it was
personal sacrifice you know just which
yeah I mean I don't I don't know if I
recommend that to a lot of filmmakers to
do that and and a lot of filmmakers have
a lot of success crowdfunding and all
that and and I I just never really
understood how they even do that you
know I just I I never understood like
the mystery of IndieGoGo and like
Kickstarter I just don't I I don't get
it
like I don't understand how they get
this money I just don't and so I've
never had any success with like any sort
of those craft funding campaigns and
I've tried a couple including that one I
just haven't had any success with them
and so just but it was like you know I
was like you know what I'm not gonna
like just drop this and then just cuz
like I've you know I don't I just I just
add especially that sound like I needed
to make a feature like I just and if I
was gonna like you know I just lived
like really cheaply and just lived
really like uncomfortably you know and
and just so I could save money and just
like put it all towards the movie and
them but yeah yeah so with all the
trials and tribulations with drifter and
your goal yeah to me to make a film
before 30 film eventually ended up on
Netflix yeah I mean it was um yeah it
was pretty quick turnaround too which is
quite shocked I mean like it was yeah
the whole like first quarter of like
2017 last year was pretty hectic because
it was like cuz I I was like and I was
prepping I was like in the thickness of
like prepping master party and being
with all these actors to that and and
then drifter was like screening at UCLA
and then it finally went to had a little
theatrical run at this like art house
theater in Hollywood and then it and
then it went to iTunes and like Amazon
and all that afterwards and then like
and then once we were filming master
party
I went to Netflix on in May of last year
so no one had any more excuses to not
watch the movie so like everyone started
to watch it then and that like that
helps so much they went to Netflix and
and you know it's like you know when it
goes an F likes you guys they you start
to like learn about the darkness of the
Internet and the trolls and and and the
you know everyone has an opinion and
everyone loves to comment and a certain
point they all just start saying the
same thing and you just stop you know
you start like you know just I don't you
know you don't there's no point
responding to any of them I just don't
respond to anyone you know like I mean
if they're like obnoxious comments you
know it's like you just didn't get the
movie like but um but yeah I mean like I
definitely like helped a lot I mean cuz
like the people then there were people
that like totally loved and totally got
what the movie was and and you know it's
you know got some very nice messages
from people and some not so nice
messages from people and so so you know
it's like but you know like that's
that's now if you're gonna if you're
gonna make movies I mean like just gotta
be thick-skinned you know it's like you
just gotta embrace it you know but like
but yeah it was yeah it was it was very
interesting a time when when Lert like
because I just wasn't expecting the
movie to get as much exposure as it did
I thought it was gonna you know again
like a little like you know I'm small
you know a small distributor and just
like sort of like just move on but then
like when I'm like like The Hollywood
Reporter's writing about and like any
wires right now like all and and then
it's like you know really getting
released all over the world I'm like
well there you are you know and and
every decision you made is all up there
for everyone to watch and but it's like
I don't you know it's like I don't
regret anything it's like I look back
it's like I mean that's exactly the
movie I wanted to make you know like so
it's like I mean I just want to be just
push the soundtrack push all that stuff
just maximize the aesthetic and to see
where you got to pull back for later
movies
cuz this most part Dooly it's like you
know it's a similar kind of like you
know kind of genre hybrid kind of
storytelling but like I mean it's still
a very different movie at the same time
like all the mistakes that I learned on
that movie that people had no problem
telling me about I I feel like I learned
a lot from that because I always read
like you know handful of bad reviews and
all that but you just want to lay
you're like no what what bothers people
what doesn't work for people and and you
know like just fix that stuff and and
and you know like Massa probably spent
like a year on the script you know I
just wanted to make sure that it was you
know I mean just the an improvement I
just want to make sure if anything else
I just want to make sure was an
improvement i I feel like it is yeah
it's interesting because I was watching
an interview with Margaret Atwood it was
a BBC documentary or something and she
was talking about her first book they
blew out the numbers that they had
projected yeah and someone gave her the
advice and you just looked at her knee
said now they can shoot at you yeah and
especially to where does this darkness
come from yeah he must have gone through
these traumatic things no this is just
what I write about you don't have to
have experienced them to go to that
level of darkness and so yeah she talked
about it as well so that flipside of wow
I mean did you really think that drifter
was going to get to that level
when you were making it or you just
needed to fulfill a goal for yourself
I'd need a feel fulfilled goal and I had
I had no idea that was gonna get the
kind of exposure it got and I think it
was great in the long run I mean it did
everything I needed it to do
so I've no regrets about any of them but
you know I mean like I you know I mean
like if there was if there is one regret
I just wish we spent a little more time
in the screenplay and I wasn't so
unbelievably in patience you know
because I'm a very antsy kind of person
and but but now I've like grown so much
I think as a filmmaker after that
because that movie like kind of changed
a lot of things though I want to
approach things so it's like now it's
like I'm I've like grown to actually
love writing now and like want to spend
a lot of time on the screenplay and not
just want to you know cuz I think
Drifter I was just like at that point I
was really concerned about just like
visual construction and like and
composition and aesthetic and in style
that movies all that style there's you
know it's all but the mood and the
atmosphere and the music and style
there's nothing really much more to it
it's that's very much with that it's
like a big music video or something and
and that's just like that's at that time
that was the kind of movie I want to
make and now I'm much more interested in
like proper character development proper
narrative because I that's why I mean
drifter was a very particular kind of
movie because like you and my shorts or
nothing like that
at all it was like that movie I was like
let me just get this like ultimate
nostalgic movie out of my system and and
just purge myself and you know just
chock-full of all the stuff that I've
always wanted to do you know just the
things that um I've loved growing up and
all these like all these obscurities and
just like push everything to the max for
beginning to end and and just see where
it lands you know and it was very like I
was very polarizing movie when it came
out I thought was a very interesting
reaction and movie gothics I was like
really just such a small tiny little
movie and you know it generated like a
very like polarizing emotion from people
like a lot of people take it very
personally with that movie like they
were the way they were like reacting to
it so I was like I mean it's like I say
as long as they react it's like I don't
care if they love it or hate it I just
want people to react to it and I have an
opinion about it you know whether it's
good or not cuz like you know if you
really good or if you believe the good
reviews you have to believe the bad
reviews so it's like at a certain point
it all just becomes like moot and just
like you just don't you know like
they're all helpful but it's like they
don't they you shouldn't let what he was
like because they the good reviews don't
matter in the batter views don't matter
and like in the grand scheme of things
but like I think it's just good to you
know just read them a little bit not
being so distant from them because I
think they're taking the time to write
about your movie they might be crapping
all over it but they are taking the time
to write about them and I mean at the
time when Holly reporter liked it I was
like I was like wow it's like a tough
tough business when I you know eight
they gave her a review there was a you
know not not not the best and and and
and it's like you know they're not wrong
like that's how they feel and but I I
just like reading that stuff in like
even even when they're criticizing it
they're still complimenting it inside of
those crews you know it's like you know
I think a lot of people thought it was
like a much bigger movie so I mean like
you know I don't think like it being a
small movie should ever dictate how
harsh you're gonna be on something it's
still just the movie itself but it's
like I do think some people literally
did think that it was like a million
dollar and like and and it you know just
wasn't at all it was like you know like
peanuts I just and so I mean I thought I
was kind of funny that like they were
kind of giving almost like backhanded
compliments and what
but you know yeah well you know I think
embrace the embrace the bad reviews
embrace all that stuff because it's just
all part of making movies you know how
did you get a distribution deal for it
my cinematographer had a came across a
sales agent at the South by Southwest
early 2015 and he'd asked him if he had
any movies that he was working on like
horror films and this was one that he
we're in soft prep for and no I met with
him right before we about the shoot and
then he switched over to a different
company like a sales agency company and
then he just kept on kept in touch with
the movie I was like sending MALDI
Stills and he came to set a couple times
and then and then then we cut a trailer
for the American film market in 2015
which was very very much like just its
commercial other trailers we can make it
just very much like straight forward
action thriller cannibal movie and like
our movie it's like not that at all I
mean it has all that stuff in it but
it's not it's a weird note and so you
know make a trailer to like show an AFM
and I get buyers to be interested in it
and and there was like a couple
distributors that he was constantly
talking to for a while while we were
editing the film and I hated showing
work-in-progress versions of the movie
I'm like no one's gonna truly be able to
experience this movie until it's mixed
like this is like it's just a very
specific kind of like hybrid tonal poem
kind of like whacked-out kind of
experience and like the soundtrack is so
paramount for this movie and like
Tencent like I just need to finish the
movie before you truly see what this
thing is and I think that almost about
everything it's like I just I never
think the movie is good until it's
finished I just don't I mean and when I
say finished I mean like a mixed like
that I think the mixing is like the
temple for the movie and people
underestimate that a lot just like
adjusting volumes but I think it's like
really much more than that and all the
little nuances really dictate the
experience and yeah and he was like so
he was I really loyal in the film and
and then yeah I mean we were the couple
months after we finished the movie in
like April 2016 we had like a little
friends-and-family screening and then a
couple months later we were able to lock
in like a u.s. distributor and then
learning all about like deliverables and
all like we're getting like the document
it was like it gives you a migraine like
your brain starts bleeding just like
reading all these things just like oh my
god a nightmare but but then you show
it's like you know your sound mixer and
your editor and your assistant editor
and then it's much more you know they
understand it much more clear it's just
so so overly technical the way it's
described and it's so many things they
gotta send but but yeah I mean like then
you know then yeah like we are of the
and you know they ended up releasing the
movie in like February of 2017 but
Australia released the film first like
around Halloween of 2016 so I was like
on DVD out there and then and then after
that like then the following spring and
started like snowball and go US and
Canada and Germany and all these
different places and and almost seeing
all these like fake posters that like
Germany made and always that and see
things like hey clothes just like you
know some are awesome actually it but
like some I see them it's like well it's
it's good artwork but it's like it's so
unbelievably is all like sign we're like
one poster said like like like like the
Book of Eli meets whatever it's like
this movie is like it's like a it's like
a weird like acid trip David Lin Chi and
keV it's like not it's you know it has
like cool action stuff in it but it's
like not you know it's not like this
movie that you're just describing to
people you know so I thought that was
kind of like kind of funny but excited
like some people when they see the movie
you're like no but I just think that I
think that's kind of fun though when
people like sometimes like are marketed
something and then they see something
like when drive came out and everyone
thought it was like that's the Furious
and they're something we're saying why
is this but I think it's a nice surprise
that sometimes you know how did making
your first feature film and then getting
feedback on that film impact how you
write things now Oh usually I mean oh
massively I mean cuz I mean we'll make a
dresser I mean I you know I'm gonna be
very very honest I was not focusing that
much on screenplay on narrative on
pedestrian plodding on care development
I was very very much more focused on
cold exercise in style and like that's
like very much making scene after scene
of stuff that I love and trying to like
have a thin story like stitch together
with like duct
like that's like that was 100% the
intention for that movie but then like I
mean I yeah thinking like we were
getting like a lot of like feedback like
an editing of it and and you know I knew
that you know there were some
irreparable problems in the movie that
work dictated by like the weakness of
the screenplay and then you know coming
you know shot myself in the foot a
little bit by rushing into it a little
bit and and because you know people were
just so they were just taking the movie
so seriously and like they were just
like being so like film-school
analytical about so many things like you
know cuz the movies like you know it's
it's a I mean if there is a story in
like the kind of story it is it's a
movie that kind of like it's one of
those kind of movies where it starts off
one thing and the buddy and it's a very
much different thing it's like keeps on
transforming itself it's sorta like it's
like hybrid genre mashup kind of story
which is definitely movie I want to make
it a time and I still think it's a fun
picture when I watch it um take sure I
said like I'm in the 40s when I just
said that I mean like but but yeah I
mean like gotta like with monster party
I mean like you know that was like that
was a really wonderful experience
because like now I have like you know
there's a much more pressure on that
movie I had a lot of producers involved
a lot of like great people involved a
lot of people that are much more
experienced than I am people that are
extremely brutally honest from the word
go from the writing stage all the way
through to the filming of it's about
editing of it and to the sound the music
everything I'd like people you know
watching every element of that movie and
they're all like you know very strong
collaborators and I really like and I
really love to working with these guys
and like that I think that was great
it's like III think like would your
tried like I wanted like I think an
idiot maybe I'd like that that's what I
like I think that was like I was always
wanting like there was like heavy
hitting cutthroat producers they were
just say like Chris this is not working
like we have to you know we have to like
you know fix this because you're gonna
kill you're gonna shoot yourself in the
foot later on you know in the editing so
and I had a lot of that most part like
you know I a lot of people like no could
you get so inside the movie and and and
you need those outside perspectives and
you know I don't really have much of
that on juror
I really had you know because we were
kind of all friends with each other and
kind of all kind of came up together so
you know they weren't being as harsh as
they might have should should have been
and uh well most party you know though
that was not the case you know and so
I'm like but I think the other thing
that was great in long run because at
the end a it's the movie it's not your
auteur personality it's not it's not
like you know you're you know a cool
style I mean it's the movie I mean I
have certain points not even you're a
movie anymore it's like that you know
has to be as accessible as possible and
I think and so that must party really
was a great transition for me to it was
almost like a new chapter in my life to
really kind of like explore new
territory and really um you know go back
to like I guess the roots of like the
storytelling that I was attracted to and
and and just really approach it from a
much more mature angle and um and you
know kind of have a soundtrack and the
style sort of like organically climb
inside the movie a little bit more and
not sort of hijack the movie like
drifter was doing and but yeah I know I
mean like I mean I'm yeah I'm but I'm
very proud of the experience in Monster
Brian very proud of the movie yeah do
you think most of the characters that
you say your main character in in any
one of your features do they really go
through like the hero's journey because
it's in some ways it's different horror
movies not going to end necessarily in a
great light where yes this hero has
realized our potential or save something
and it's it's often not the case yeah I
mean like I mean drifter I was like
trying to do that but I Moscow
definitely I would say as a hero's
journey story I mean like I I I do but I
am very attracted to like stories that
are populated by I like like more ow
details I like movies that have like a
moral tightrope that cared that like the
characters are walking the alley
character might do something that you
might not totally agree with there might
be a little messed up but um and I'm
gonna challenge you if you still want to
keep going on that ride with
I mean like a movie that I mean a really
random example that I bring up because
it's so notorious for being me so bad
it's good even though I think it's a
genuinely really fun movie as showgirls
you know which I love showgirls it's
great like I'm not saying that
ironically I really enjoy that the first
time I saw wasn't my mother it was a
very weird experience but but I mean
like what's really fascinating about
that movie that I'm trying to do and
certainly try to do a must party a lot
was um every character in a movie is
kind of like a little like you know kind
of like has badness in them like I mean
they might disguise but they're all kind
of like very they have bad bad qualities
mouths and even like now know me like
the main character and there's like the
only innocent character in that movie is
like the girls like the makeup artist
and she gets punished for being innocent
in this world of horrible people
and she gets punished quite horribly and
people forget about that really horrible
scene I'm a third act with her and the
rock star guy and like that's a very
eye-opening vicious scene that she gets
punished for being good at being a good
pure person around these terrible people
including the lead character and like
that's that's sort of like what I try to
dabble in with moss party like that
where it's like because you know it's
sort of like very flawed people again
it's even more flawed people and the
people that you would think would not be
flawed or way more flawed than you
could've possibly imagined and but there
are a couple there are innocent people
in the movie that that get extremely
punished for being very genuine and and
like that's like that's the kind of I
mean that that's always been so I don't
I I mean it sounds like a sick way of
looking at things but that's always been
sort of like them that's always been
sort of like the the outlook that I've
always like saw the world and you know
like we're you know just sometimes like
good deeds go
you know like later so like no good deed
goes unpunished or whatever in light and
and just innocent people paying the
price for being what they are and bad
people serve having this power and like
you know just the moral corruption of of
the world and like in our society and
our generation and I'm and I'm always
like trying to make some sort of like
bold statement
how I see that I'm not just trying to
make these sort of like cool genre
movies and violence and cool stuff my um
I mean that's all fun but it's like I am
really trying to like sneak in like a
very bold statement about how I see the
world because a lot of it's very
personal I mean like it's whacked-out as
some of them some of the stuff is it is
very very personal about like the kind
of tone and the kind of the nature of
certain main carried characters we're
supposed to be rooting for like sort of
like I mean every one of them sort of
had I mean I think like when you're
making movies I think you when you're
writing stories I think you really have
to you have to put all your good traits
on screen but you also have to put a lot
of your bad traits on screen and no one
wants to see just good traits me you
have to almost embarrass yourself by
putting in really bad traits about
yourself and and and and that's just
like I mean do it in like a very fun
kind of accessible way but like um but
yeah I mean I that's like that's that's
always been a sort of like kind of those
kind of stories I've always been really
attracted to or like carry yeah I mean
like carries grave right just being
punished at home being punished I mean
that's such a cynical story and then she
yeah and then just it has no it has no
she has no other options but to like
just terrorize her prom and then she
pays the price for it like I mean that's
such like a sad what if that's a great
morality tale and I mean I don't know
there's the kind of stories that I just
think like you know because everyone has
flaws I'm like and I and her everyone
has like darkness inside of them and
some people do a better job clothing
like disguise in them but but I don't I
just I just I like movies it's really
kind of like push the boundaries of like
what are like like protagonists are
capable of and um sort of like I don't
know maybe somewhat bad people against
worse people or something you know
that's I just always been I just always
been attractive that kind of
storytelling you know right and when you
see the bad people are the ones that are
sort of the stereotypical what you think
that if you saw them in a dark alley
and sometimes those are actually aren't
the ones that are the worst yeah it's
the ones that you would think are a
little more trustworthy oh yeah I mean I
mean like I you know like what my
favorite directors is Larry Clark and
like you know how heat films like bully
and kids and Ken Park and all that and
like those films are really very
disturbing experiences but like they are
characters that are I mean like I very
much around those kind of people like my
brother was very much like he he's very
much friends with those kind of kids so
I I just like I think a lot of that kind
of stuff like hearing really revolting
things that these kids would say and
seeing stuff that they would do and
hearing stories about them what they
would do and and I think a lot of that
stuff like III try to translate in sort
of like a you know I guess cinematic
format and try to go back to that kind
of that's just like no that's just the
way it just comes from like up you know
just growing up and the kind just the
kind of people I was around in high
school and all that just the kind of
things that I saw and you know just the
yeah I mean like I just and just just
really you know disturbing tragic things
that are happening with people and that
was always um I mean I just you know
it's at a certain point you can't quite
see the world in any other way and so
until you get into like you were later
years but like but I I'm just like I'm
just like very stemming on like how I
how the world was around me growing up
like the kind of people that I
interacted with or the kind of people
that I grew up around and they're good
people's houses that I went to and just
the stuff I saw and like all these like
really whacked out like dysfunctional
things that were happening inside these
houses and these kids and and so yeah I
mean like I'm just that that's like I'm
just very me I'm very attract I'm just a
very attractive that that kind of that
kind of stuff and I just really making
it as grounded as possible but you know
in like a cinematic cinematic kind of
way which one of your films are you most
proud of
well I mean like I mean I am very very
very proud of most important I mean I
mean like as far as like maybe a short I
mean this uh I mean the short cut like
white trash
it was like 2040 shot in 2013 and played
a few festivals in 2014 that that was
like probably as far as like the short
films probably like I mean that was like
definitely the most commercial thing I'd
ever made and it was like that's like
the most well received as well it was
just that different yeah I was a
different you know it was a it was like
a female lead story and it was a very
like I just it was I don't know it just
it just seemed I mean it was a John
wrote piece but it was it was connected
with a lot of people and it was I was
I'm still sad they're very proud of that
movie but like yeah I mean that monster
party I think the things I'm the most
proud of I mean most worried definitely
um you know it's just uh I mean it's
it's it's it's like I think everything
I've learned in the last several years
is inside that movie and and you know I
just went through such a experience
writing Madden thing and shooting and
editing in scoring and all that stuff
and that when I finally finished the
movie I feel like I almost like saw the
world again if the first time for like
in like two years or something I was so
consumed in a movie but but it's also
one of my it's that it's actually very
personal movies twisted is is in places
and it's like the lead character is very
much a representation of me to a degree
for metaphors you know like I mean it
was very much like you know and it was
injecting a lot more personal stuff into
it that maybe I hadn't done a lot in the
past so yeah it's like matzah brei I'm
definitely very very very proud of it
this phrase called leveling up is like
this new sort of catchphrase I don't
know maybe it's been around for a while
that okay buddy and I was new to be - I
guess it means like especially and maybe
the entrepreneur world you're kind of
going to a new level and all the
problems that come up with that and you
would think it's it's good to be at that
level but really there's all these new
things that have come mm-hmm so for you
how have you dealt with let's say
leveling up whatever that means to you
whether it's having The Hollywood
Reporter write about your film having
people from all over the world have an
opinion about your film that was really
just as personal
movie that you wanted to make for
yourself by a certain time and now it's
like become a thing and it's out there
and people have an opinion how have you
dealt with the new level of pressure
that comes from being in different
stages yeah I mean III think well it was
funny because like when I was making all
these shorts it was like I was getting
so aggravated that they weren't getting
exposure then would you forgot all the
exposure I'm like oh my god like hide
under floorboards assignment but I mean
like but I mean like I like enough
people like that movie it's like to have
kept me creatively afloat it's not like
everybody you know it's like I mean I
know there was a it was a very divisive
kind of reaction which I you know I
thought I was kind of cool like um but
then with like Moz bar I was like it's
such a you know you almost think it's
gonna be like a little bit easier
because all you have to do is like
direct and write it was actually like
because like now you got like 50 person
crew you got an ensemble of like
seasoned professional actors they were
wonderful by the way it was like such a
great incredible experience working with
those actors but um but but you know you
got a lot a lot of cooks in the kitchen
a lot of years in there and as well as
they should at a Sarah you know until I
understand where they're coming from and
like either trying to you know I mean
they're trying to protect the product
and there were all just trying to make
the greatest movie we could possibly
make and but yeah I mean I think in also
dealing with trusting department heads
because I was so used to doing so many
things myself like production design and
props and all that stuff and you know it
that was a little that took me a little
bit to adapt to that but then a certain
point there's so many things that you
got it cuz like you know my spray was
was a much more dense story than drifter
my story was very he's a very plot
driven movie a lot character dynamics
like it's very very dense kind of plot
story so I mean like it was you know I
was a complicated movie to shoot and and
it just challenged me so much on so many
levels and and and like just it was
really just thrown into the atomic fire
and just like with all these all he's
like I'm here the last day the last days
read them we shot like at this mansion
in Malibu from a couple weeks in lay
there like a bunch of people inside like
the last day we were there and was like
and a lot of them are like friends and
all that I play I mean oh yeah I mean
like this is like a everyone's watching
you and all that like and you just but
you know at a certain point to serve
like to net stuff out and just focus on
what's what what you have to do and lie
and and you know all those you know all
those people sort of just um yeah I mean
you just gotta focus on like like the
movie that you're trying to make and not
get like we were saying before like
what's inside the frame and not good to
distract it and all that and you know
and it's tough you know it's it's it's
like well I mean it was it was stuff
like going it's like from a movie with a
skeleton crew it's like a movie with
like whoa this is you know like um but
it was now but like in the grand scheme
of things it was it was an awesome
experience though I mean it was just
like because they just trained me so
hard to like yeah just challenged pushed
me so hard it like it just challenged me
so hard and and it just um
you know it just it really like if you
can get through that it's like it makes
you if it's almost like I kind of looked
at like movie boot camp a little bit you
know which you know I feel you got to go
through it you know you got to go
through and it was very much like a boot
camp and but a very like in a good way
and the grand scheme of things no very
strong yeah is there any inspiring story
around your first feature film drifter
that led you to the producing team
behind your second feature monster party
I mean I I was you know introduced to
the the the producer for monster party
through through drifter and I threw
someone that was involved in that movie
and uh so that that was that was
probably like the biggest thing I mean I
what but also I I think what you're
through I think um I mean like you're if
they're really I think you know like I
mean like like whatever people like
think about the movie itself it's like
you know it is a very confidently made
movie from an aesthetic point of view
and like and I think perhaps like
producers were very they responded to
that very well because they knew that it
was a very micro budget and like they I
think that just gave them a lot of
confidence to think that you know maybe
maybe you know this kid can do this
we're a little bigger budget than we're
initially thinking about and you know
the script also you know didn't need it
you know I needed that you know but yeah
I mean I think it just really I think
enhanced people's confidence that that
you know I you know I can you know
because the bad movie was very you know
very ambitious with what we were trying
to do as well so it's like I'm just I'm
very attracted to you know ambitious
kind of storytelling and sort of just
trying to make the movies as cinematic
as possible for you know very little
money and and you know and and I think
they just I think drifting really kind
of like it as far as well as like the
actors as well as well ii came on board
that helped a lot with them and it just
you know just enhance a lot of people's
confidence that like you know i can you
know that i can i can i can sculpt the
film i can i I understand like working
with actors and truncated schedules and
executing aesthetic and story and all
that and so yeah I mean I definitely
helped quite a bit I mean yeah I mean I
think that and you know the script for
monster party I think both those things
you know just certainly helped along do
you get bored easily yeah okay I was
wondering does because that then takes
you to a new it seems like you're
constantly pushing yourself upward with
things yeah me I just like um cuz I just
like every time I make it finish a movie
I just watch it way too many times like
even when it's done i watch it like too
many times because I'm trying to I think
what every look is I do that I've been
doing that since like my first shorts I
mean I and I think what I'm trying to do
is like I'm trying to watch it so many
times that I just hate it so much
because I've seen all the mistakes and
all the problems that drive me nuts
watching it that I don't I I want to
just tally up all those mistakes and
just fix them on the next one and then
I'll watch that and think you know all
the mistake and fix them on the next one
and I think like that's so I think with
like each movie it's like you know
there's always like massive I mean that
there's so many the biggest thing that
crush main stretches Niall off
filmmakers that they kind of move
sideways a little bit they're always
they're not really the other movies are
you know cool and stylish and all that
but like they're not really they kind of
all blend in with each other they kind
of all look this
same like they kind of all have just
sort of feel about them that they feel
like I know I can't tell like when was
this movie made first or second I mean
like right you know it's that you want
to make sure the light you know this is
the most recent thing you've done
because of the strongest you've done and
like and you're only as good as your
last movie and I mean didn't even knew
of anything isn't incredible there and
did like Blade Runner and like Sicario
and all that he's like and he's a guy
that's just always and he just crank and
movie after movie after I mean he's just
always like bettering himself more and
more and like um and I'm just not a you
know I think I'm just upbringing I'm
just I've just never been like a cocky
person you know I've just never I've
never been comfortable with you know
family Gras being good like you're
always getting like criticized about
every single thing you're doing and
always being commented by on every
single thing you're doing and so it's
like I think I grew up like never
thinking any thing that I did was like
up to snuff like ever good and like you
know I just would constantly feel like
the next one oh the next one is gonna be
the one and like that's how I always saw
where it's like almost like everything
in the past doesn't even like mean
anything it's like I'm always like
starting off fresh again is if I never
made a movie or something like that's
like how I always serve like look at and
I just you know I just never been like a
self-satisfied kind of person I mean
just like I just I mean there's so many
people out there they're just like so
they're just so like you know Bolin like
they're so cocky and like so overly
confident with their stuff and
especially you know I don't like God
it's like it's revolting honestly but
but yeah now just never I just never
been that personality you know because
I've just know because I've learned the
hard way on so many things for years and
you know I've taken a sledgehammer in
the face for years and I and just with
endless relentless failure all the time
and so it's like I just I'm just
grateful enough to I even be in this
industry and I'm just very grateful for
all the opportunities and and just
trying to keep on making it very clear
that that that that you know that you
deserve to be in that position and so
it's like you want to keep bettering
yourself and learning from your mistakes
and getting stronger and stronger and
way up and it's like that's that's
always been my mentality
no is it almost better in some ways
though there's sometimes people that
have had it so easy I don't think
they're pushed enough oh yeah I mean
like that like the people that outside
that like kind of move sideways was the
ones that are like they get successful
right out the gate like every movie they
make goes to these prestigious film
festivals and all that I see these stuff
I'm like no I yeah how do you get that
there and and you know I just um I mean
yeah I mean I I'm really I'm not a yeah
I mean like you know I think it's great
to have like a perfect movie it's your
first movie coming out and all these
accolades and all these awards but you
know I mean like if you want a long
career you know it's like you're gonna
be compared to that for the rest of your
life and like you know I've always and
they some people can do that really well
I think Damien Chazelle I think he's
gonna have an awesome crew him and he's
well those guys that like keeps on Craig
I'm not really well-liked but um but
yeah I mean III was like being the sort
of life of John Carpenter kind of rude
Rob Rodriguez kind of rude just sort of
like just keep making movies working
working away I've been getting better
and better and it's kind of working away
after that you know because I would love
to make big movies I mean like I just I
feel like I I feel like I can't really
make small movies like I I just I I
don't know I just um
I just I loved like cinematic story like
big set pieces and like I just love like
like scope my and like we got to shoot
monster party and anamorphic and it was
like my first time shooting an
anamorphic and was wonderful it was
Grant
it was like you know just this could you
know it was just a really wonderful
experiment to shoot an anamorphic lenses
and was wonderful but um but yeah